i thought he's back that kid on the tv
just called me a [ __ ] again
noob master yeah noob master 69
according to this new master hey it's
thor again you know the god of thunder
listen buddy if you don't log off this
game immediately i'm gonna fly over to
your house come down to that basement
you're hiding in
rip off your arms and shove them up your
butt oh that's right yes go cry to your
father little weasel
i think you thought hey let me know if
he bothers you again okay thank you very
much
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and marvel has finally revealed who
this mysterious
noob master 69 is after the famous scene
an avengers in game where korg is
playing xbox live he's playing fortnite
he says that somebody's yelling at him
the guy is back
new master 69 clearly an arch enemy of
video games for
thor and korg as we can tell based off
of how thor reacts to him
threatening to rip off his arms and
shove them up his butt
and for the longest time since avengers
in-game about two years people
have been wondering who exactly is this
a lot of theories stated that it's
probably somebody like deadpool which i
thought was a really cool idea
and somebody who i would have loved to
have seen play noob master 69 once he
entered the mcu
or another new character who could have
had a pretty cool scene with thor
at some point in time down the line in
taika watiti's thor love and thunder
but it is actually somebody who has
already been seen in the marvel
cinematic universe and no it is not a
superhero just kind of a normal person
he was actually seen in captain america
winter soldier
and with all of the promos going out
right now for the falcon and the winter
soldier
it looks like marvel and xbox decided
that it was time to reveal the identity
of this mysterious new master 69 and
they did it in this commercial that they
released right here
they're a superhero though you probably
do awesome stuff like this all the time
oh not exactly like this
you ever been in a car chase i fly dude
marvel studios the falcon in the winter
soldier original series streaming march
19th on disney plus
my gamer tag is noob master 69.
my cousin made it now as you can see on
his name tag his name is
aaron and we've seen him before if you
don't recognize him you can actually
find him in captain america winter
soldier in this clip right here
can i help you guys with anything oh no
my fiance was just helping me with some
honeymoon destinations
right we're getting married
congratulations were you guys thinking
about going
new jersey
i have the exact same glasses wow you
two are practically twins
yeah i wish specimen
uh if you guys need anything i've been
aaron thank you
it looks like he went from working at an
apple store to working at an xbox or
microsoft store
and he is apparently new master 69 the
person who has been troubling thor
korg and meek now it's pretty cool to
finally have his identity revealed but i
know a lot of people think that this is
pretty underwhelming including myself i
think we could have made it deadpool or
somebody more interesting
but he does say that his cousin made it
for him so perhaps maybe it was his
cousin who was messing with thor korg
and meek
maybe taika watiti will address this
again in thor love and thunder or maybe
aaron really is new master 69 either way
let me know what you think about this in
the comments down below are you happy
that new master 69 is finally revealed
or would you have rather had somebody
else be revealed to be this character
no offense to the aaron guy he's a funny
dude i just wish it was deadpool but let
me know in the comments down below don't
forget to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest mcu news and
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me